il y avait eu marre et jacques rouland
vous êtes l'un et l'autre est
responsable
producteur de la caméra invisible
comment êtes vous arrivé à mettre la
technique à au service des besoins de la
caméra invisible hier qu'il faut tout
d'abord dire que nous n'aurions pas pu
faire cette émission il y a quelques
années
en effet c'est la miniaturisation de
tous les moyens techniques qui permet
aujourd'hui de faire la caméra vise sans
aucun doute en fait nous travaillons
avec les techniques du respirable
se passant vous l'avez reconnu ces gens
france elle que cache-t-il sous son
manteau tout simplement du matériel
portatif utilisé pour l'émission caméra
invisible c'est un émetteur à transistor
qui est en liaison avec un récepteur
ultra sensibles installées à bord d'une
petite voiture équipée pour
l'enregistrement sonore à quelques
mètres de là un camion anonyme c'est la
centrale images il est équipé de caméras
spéciales d'opter suivant le cas
d'objectifs à très longue focale exemple
avec le 500 mm il est parfaitement
possible de cadrer en gros plan un
personnage éloigné d'environ 50 mètres
le rôle essentiel de la peur s'est
ingénié à disparaître il ya peu toute la
technique qui était mis à ma disposition
consiste à effacer leurs éleveurs car
quand il s'agit de retransmettre la
vérité - les attributs techniques
plus près de nous serons une restitution
spontanée
l'action que nous voulons transmettre
vos fusée systématique mode avec les
esclaves la technique ah oui absolument
et prendre d'ailleurs un des succès et
qui est à la base des caméras à j 6
c'est d'ailleurs un des succès de la
technique aussi
car à partir du moment où on refuse des
escarres de teknika technique suit cela
prouve donc que les techniciens sont des
champions au comptoir jacques legras qui
joue le personnage du patron de monsieur
emile va vendre à des comédiens compères
des billets de 1000 francs 2000 francs
anciens mais tenez vous bien il va les
vendre ses billets pour la somme
exorbitante de 500 francs c'est à dire
exactement à moitié prix rires c'est
l'aubaine son éclaireur 2005 fn 13 mai
nous avons trouvé de nombreux acquéreurs
pour acheter le billet à l'effigié de
voltaire à moitié pour donner mon chez
moi je kiffe audition
oui je m'intéressais par le biais de
wade a dit ward du front de terre oui
oui donnez moi combien
[Musique]
voulez vous les 200 france 4
ça vous intéresse vraiment partir les au
moins dix vies mais je suis pas sûr de
l'état voir ça je crois que vous gardez
le sourire que c'est très bien c'est
quoi parce que c'est pour la caméra
invisible c'est pour la caméra elle se
dit oui
la caméra sur lui c'est une mission de
la rtf oui c'est pour la télé alors que
vous êtes filmés
[Musique]
on ça c'est pas mal et puis je voulais
rentrer alors non non pensée noire
c'est amusant koné avait remis une comme
un génial de retrouver successivement
jacques legras andré baron et jacques
rouland vous faire démonstration que on
peut agir sur des personnes avec des
objets aussi simple qu'un oeuf et une
salière et quelques phrases sans grand
sens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
pas chaud jean louis borloo
alors
ce soir 22h sans faute
[Musique]
[Rires]
gamer
il ya une question d'heures entre nous
c'est quelle heure on vous a dit alors
il ya une erreur fait main d'enfant
avant cui la caméra invisible c'est
merchez comédiens piétons traversent
hors des clous et obligent les
automobilistes a freiné brutalement à la
surprise générale jacques legras les
interpellent pour les complimenter
[Musique]
traverser et qu'est ce que nous visons à
la baille en avril puis 3000 a traversé
son chauffeur et oui oui je sais ce
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
maintenant que vous avez fait vous êtes
un besoin continu vous escomptez
carrément je t'appellerai
je ne sais pas dire vous avez zappé
petit à petit
justement vous êtes arrêté il a écrasé
ses papiers la face et c'est justement
le nom compagne voilée par les pavés
c'est une part on est à vous remercier
pour la caméra
nous on arrête des voitures pour l'envoi
des choses agréables c'est normal
marantz même remercié pour la camair
invisible
laquelle je connais à merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
séquence que nous allons vous présenter
maintenant s'intitule le fou et les deux
infirmiers
elles se passent devant le kiosque que
vous voyez là jacques legras va arriver
et demandé à cette marchande des
journaux qui n'existe plus depuis
longtemps
c'est le matin
le matin oui
pour mettre le jeu journal le matin est
ce que paris soit réparé par histoire
non force d'apparitions et vous allez
voir que le fait de demander ces
journaux suffit pour se faire passer
pour un fou pourquoi échanges chaud
comme ça
le fonds fou sans étaler les deux
infirmiers vont maintenant faire leur
entrée en scène a vu passer par ici
pantin
j'ai vu son manteau jaune quand il est
parti de la voiture est annoncée pas
dangereux le matin il est d'éviter
sharif
comment
là bas vous détendre oui vous n'avez pas
le journal journal de demain va arriver
encore
[Musique]
[Rires]
à
on part dont les chaises qui s'est
[Rires]
maintenant à l'olympia
gilbert bécaud et j'aime autant vous
dire que le jour de la première il y
avait du monde et du beau monde
mais nous on nous invite pas aux
premières alors on s'invite et tout seul
on est venu igor a mis des caméras
partout et qui on a fait des petites
plaisanteries aux personnalités qui
étaient invités le jour de la première
bonsoir comment ça va ça vient ça fait
bien comment ça va le plaisir de voir
bonsoir
comment ça va
alors pour voir fabien filmé par la
caméra
le rendement
tu faisais bien emma parce qu'avec ce
temps la fiction n'a pas quelque chose
que je voulais le nez
merci infiniment monsieur cela vous êtes
sûr
ainsi on est alors excusez-moi troisième
phase i avec le
la gérante j'ai moi aussi dire merci à
barr qui s'adapte à la bouche a remporté
ce prix c'est de la mienne ce but
qu'elle marque service à l'horizon pour
moi c'est de la bleue coin voici
maintenant une seconde réaction un peu
plus généreuses en ses moyens de
fonctionner ainsi
m
non non at il ajouté non sous la roche
et enfin voici une 3ème réaction une
réaction des gens très généreux qui ne
veulent pas laisser ce pauvre de chars
avec ce petit mes goûts non non non je
vais peut-être vous ont demandé une
autre pour après moumoute et peut-être
peut-être apprendre pour ce soir alors
matin après mon petit déjeuner j'aime
bien une cigarette marché il m'a après
déjeuner
excellent joueur non mais j'ai mon frère
qui est bienvenu mais aussi alors on
connaît ces pratiques le despote
on peut raconter n'importe quoi c'est ça
qui est épatant on n'est même pas obligé
de vous dire autre chose arrive et nous
a obligés de téléphoner soi même on
aurait demandé à sa secrétaire de le
faire est ce que je peux te donner ainsi
le risque c'est que vous pourriez me
composer un numéro
mais quand on n'a pas de secrétaire on
peut le mode à une dame qui passe comme
ça de jouer le rôle de la secrétaire ça
vous paraît impossible
et bien c'est pourtant ce qu'a fait
l'autre jour jacques legras alors il
pourra pas manquer ce soir
tadic qui a dîné à la maison votre mère
qui vend sa mère qui vient manger
bonjour oui
les côtés dit vick les affaires sont les
affaires de famille n'est rose amer
alors elle ne me suis dit il comme ça
que kenzy qui peuplera qu'il pourra pas
venir dans ma préférence qu'il a à faire
je ne vais plus vite ou plus jeunes
gilles marini que cet achat nouveau
maire a dit que c'est bien sa mère
qu'elle habitait chez vous il
démissionner comme ça qu'ils rencontrent
mettre en avant 15 jours trois semaines
je sais pas parce que vous pourriez
faire on fait venir
mr une fois de temps en temps quand on
habite avec vous comme et l'écouté son
mari vous savez quand madame excusez moi
vous remercier parce que vous m'avez
rendu service à vous êtes être gentil
vous allez passer sur la deuxième chance
pour la caméra invisible et vous êtes
filmés à col blanc
vous le voyez toutes les rues sont à peu
près semblable
toutes les maisons se ressemblent sont
des petits pavillons généralement
construit dans le même style et un petit
peu sur sur le même modèle et pour le
reconnaître il y à un seul moyen c'est
la plaque indicatrices l'un de ces
pavillons situés avenue des tilleuls est
occupée par jacques legras et par sa
maman
la comédienne hélène dieudonné se sont
vus chez nos cousins ils attendent pour
but
serhat 25 allée des marronniers taxi est
donc parti et pendant ce temps là un
complice de la caméra invisible va
changer la plaque il y avait allée des
tilleuls pour m allée des marronniers
complètement égaré d'autre part par les
explications d'hélène dieudonné le
chauffeur de taxi va réapparaître
exactement au même endroit se fiant à la
plaque indicatrices changé il croît de
bonne foi être arrivé à destination
ali des marronniers bataille et attend
déjà ses valises à vouloir le stopper
c'est une histoire de coup je me laisse
guider mais on a fait un tour notre
affreux jojos de services dissimulé
change la plaque à nouveau et l'allée
redevient l'allée des tilleuls 27 allée
des marronniers c'est bien ici elle n'a
pas voulu y aller alors ici c'est
l'année des tilleuls
d'après les pompiers la rue de viella
venez allée des marronniers
mais le nom de dieu même ici c'est
l'allée des tilleuls
ah ben on l'a changé de planque un an
non ça fait longtemps j'ai vu d'ici ça
toujours été l'allée des tilleuls
savané d'ici à lui si ça les lombards
elle veut pas y aller c'est sa toute
façon ça n'a pas d'importance puisque
c'était pour la caméra invisible
vous étiez filmé par la caméra sais pas
si je comprenais plus rien du tout mais
vous pourriez s'il vous plaît ou ou
prendre une photo de ma femme et moi la
rue
obama alors que va-t-il se passer
jacques legras et de mme edith pages
vont confier cet appareil truqués un
passant qui n'en sais rien bien entendu
ce brave monsieur va essayer les prendre
en photo et tu vois bien sûr tout de
suite le résultat va avoir quelques
difficultés à se trouver en difficulté
merci on va regarder tout ceci est ma
femme coupée riz complet mais vous vous
prendra j'étais bien cadré mon chéri
merci ma femme et moi on était très bien
sérieux parce que je suis dans une
position tout à l'heure ah là là vous
avez pris moi ça c'est moi je vous
montrais doit rester à côté moment je me
suis allé jouer et montrer à monsieur
souris bien bas sourit il eh ben vous
voyez les chollima femme regarde et on
essaie de reprendre une photo comme
voilà
ah c'est peut-être vauvert c'est
possible c'est très agréable au lieu
d'avoir une magnifique souvenir de paris
mais après on ne sait pas si vous
appuyez trop tôt sinon vous étiez en
face - nous avons appuyé un couteau
regardèrent voilà on était là la
commande qui n'était pas sa confiance à
répétition excusez moi qui vais vous
faire un cadeau de vous en train de nous
prendre vous voyez pas ce que c'était
pour la caméra invisible
c'était dans l'émission de la seconde
chaîne la caméra avec bonjour monsieur
c'est le noël des contractuels vous êtes
rênes de votre actuelle oui eh ben mon
vieux de bien ventées oui avec robert
blake une plage des étrennes des
contractuels qui est une certification
si c'est pour le 29 nov les étrennes des
contrats je ne partirai volet tatihou et
un costume blagues et on a décidé comme
ça dans les boutiques
non mais vous plaisantez ou par les
agissements ça vous paraît tellement 1
restera retardé par extraordinaire
moi j'ai dit que j'étais prêt mais on
n'est pas des très nombreuses années
bien au post ils ont même
oui bah alors par quel tour tu nous fais
des contraventions ou vous ont donné
c'est d'être m
méteren oui je suis parti du trend à
vous n'en avez pas reçu non même école
là une ample mais vous les jeux dit
tout les petits papillons qu'on paye ah
bah ça nous va pas nous oui je suis bien
je viens
ça ne va pas bien du tout ça c'est pas
honnête
ah oui qu'est-ce que vous allez nous
donnait alors à rien du tout
rien du tout c'est embêtant ça va tomber
temps bah oui parce qu'on ne fait pas
partie du quartier mais on se parle
entre collègues le savez je vous fais un
être vivant
oui malgré voulu évaluer votre casque
est malgré tout vous n'avez pas les
retrouver je parlais à un contractuel
vous croyez c'est ça c'était pour la
caméra invisible vous êtes filmés
l'accord autorise un petit peu culotté
je vais demander des étrennes bonjour
voila mich est pas chose dont je viens
pour les étrennes des contractuels
ficher des amants de venise
non qu'est ce que vous allez me donner
ouais bah c'est pour savoir combien vous
donner 5 francs et vous aussi parce que
j'en ai plus intéressés quand on a une
voiture évidemment vous comprenez ça
c'est tout c'est toujours la même chose
alors parce que qu'est-ce qu'on a avec
10 francs le rituel mais qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que ça me fasse
voyez vous les voulez voulait pas avec
10 francs la touche tu écoutes et là je
vais vous devez mener un papillon coin
douche appuyons ma fille un papillon au
coin d'un pour la convocation quelqu'un
pense que vous serez convoqué pour
visionner la caméra invisible puisque
c'est pour les missions d'accueil vous
avez bien beau temps aujourd'hui
moins bon qu'à hollywood bien sûr je
vous ai a reconnu monsieur perwer jeu
moser épanouie
vous attendez à paris incognito
je préférais
g berne et leur finalité importance vous
offrons nous un fond le vert donc on de
la maison entendent à une personne
connue mondialement comme souvent les
experts à la ville on a du mal à les
annuler et venait de les reconnaître
j'en suis en lisant souvent une
différence entre elles ce que l'on voit
au cinéma et le visage naturel à la vie
en vous tournez vous n'avez pas vos
lunettes jeu pour ne pas avoir à
retourner mon appartement
je suis moi c'est de se détruire
mais non vous n'auriez pas un stylo à
nous prêter s'il vous plaît merci
[Musique]
super
pour le jeu on trouve quelqu'un faisant
entrer je suis nous allons vous dire
alors qu'ils nous sommes c'est bien de
ne participer à la caméra je vais vous
le laisse dans le cadre de notre
politique d'austérité consiste à faire
des émissions de moins en moins cher
nous allons vous présenter notre
première séquence à savoir le fil
invisible
ce fils n'existe pas
ça leur laisse le besbes 13 13 passes et
qui laisse passer
cécile baisse le maire de mon passage en
être
voilà benton baisse levé ce que laisse
le côtoie un petit peu un petit peu là
pouvoir était juste là t'es juste retire
le retire le retire le là là ça va la
sauver l'euro mais leur valeur au
vélodrome 1-2 voila voila je suis loyal
et en janvier un jean bien en jambes et
voila voila cela
là c'est nouveau et j'ai avoir
légèrement légèrement légèrement geste
laisse filer le style et les fils et les
filles et les fils et les filles et les
fils et je suis très content maintenant
parce que ça enfin de trouver une place
très stable à la ftf à la meinau son de
la radio une place aux masters je suis
au renseignement
je suis plein temps là si on me demande
à l'enseignement je suis là fort pour le
donner à des récits mabanckou cause sa
chance mais je sais que vous êtes et
vous quelle classe ce que vous avez fait
pour le plus cher le fait que plusieurs
noms vous avez maintenant qu'est ce que
vous allez faire
nc pour choix vous indique si ça me
faisait des promoteurs ou monter autres
assimilés aux cadres non qu'est ce qui
est métallique est rien note 6/10 non
parce que c'est paris les 6 et 9 étages
et un monsieur d'un second cycle en solo
c'est fini oui vous allez environ 25 26
conférences des stages auprès aux
indices us mac os comme sa campagne
vous voulez bien savourer shanghai
pèsent sur ces fossés dressé alors que
vous avez demandé mon succès à moto et
surtout sur l'état nous avait tous les
rats c'est marrant volet maintenant je
peux continuer le monde est mal fait
tout le monde comme la journée evian ne
demanderait enseignement c'est d'un côté
droit oui c'est vrai c'est vrai alors
avis à droite et à gauche comment vous
les jo nesbo journal c'est pas possible
vous désabonner le jour même enseigne je
sais pour un seigneur la preuve vous
voulez oui enfin la californie beaumont
15e étage pour faire une guitare que
tous suivent
comprenez vous comprenez ça risque tout
citoyen peut se passer vous tenez tout
de suite la porte arrière après vous
arrivez tout doit vous prenez trop
attention
victoire saluant l'appréciation
s'appelle sony l'a appelé vous prenez la
sla sens à la paix de la le glas pour
détendre suivait dessus de la seine
jusqu'à là semble transparaître en tout
neuf
parce que manger et après vous trouvez
vous trouvez la rue des tours et des
tours du 7e 5 et 6 février pctv kg
bandés pour vos conversations qu'on peut
pas faciale tous les bureaux 4 5e 7e
racing toulon 25 ans pour le précieux
j'ai mal aux oreilles percées sa rocade
vous prenez tout de suite là c'est bien
tout de suite quoi la langue de tous
voté pour le nouveau 370z comme nous
rassemble tous et qu'on les étages c'est
très simple dans le forfait et vous avez
vous allez vers une douleur qui les uns
que les deux territoires 4,6 à ce qu'on
le veuille contredit alors point vous
vous prenez qu'elle arrive tout de suite
pour le grand auditorium survolé le bloc
de béton
[Musique]